il a fait un ragoût et quelques légumes
pour souper s'explique ce box une scène
des plus normales mais pourtant
extraordinaire pour sacha et ses quatre
filles elle se considère très chanceuse
d'avoir pu enfin trouvé ce nouvel
appartement subventionné par le
gouvernement prenne soin car depuis des
années trouver un endroit où habiter est
devenu un réel enfer pour la mère
monoparentale
le taux d'inoccupation à charlotte en
est passé de 1,7 pour cent en 2010 est à
0,2 pour cent en 2018 un taux inférieur
aux grandes villes canadiennes à toronto
ce taux est de 1,1 pour cent à montréal
il est de 1 9% et de 0 8% mots couverts
le coût des loyers a explosé les
propriétaires peuvent se permettre
d'être de plus en plus capricieux une
hausse démographique lié en partie à
l'immigration explique cette situation
la population est passée d'environ 144
milles à 155 mille personnes en moins de
cinq ans ajoutez à cela le phénomène
d'airbnb une industrie encore non
réglementée par la province saut de 6 à
une situation qu'ils qualifient gameboy
d'un tenable et il travaille depuis 35
ans à construire des appartements
subventionnés comme celui de sacha il a
vu la demande explose et
pour son prochain projet de 16 unités
il y a plus de 300 personnes sur la
liste d'attentes pour les acheteurs et
les vendeurs de maisons
le marché a aussi considérablement
changé et les maisons constate film muse
se vendent à la vitesse de l'éclair
l'idée d'acheter une maison pour sacha
relève de la fiction
ok les différents paliers gouvernement
s'affaire à trouver des solutions mais
elles tardent à se matérialiser
il faudra attendre deux ans avant de
voir environ 1000 appartements de plus
disponibles sur le marché
en attendant qu'ils sachent a enfin
l'impression d'être sous une bonne
étoile
d'autres attendent toujours les jours
meilleurs
ici elisa ferreira du canada charlatans